[Musique]
quand une fille une fille de Provence en
mariage VI donner main toutes les de la
Provence jusquau petit matin quand une
fille de fille Provence en mariage don
main ce son les de la Provence
quiousourins il y a ton père avec ma
mère qui dan comm y a ton grandère ma
grand-mère qui toute là-bas sont assis
sur un banc il y a pasce la tentalis le
percepteur et Monsieur le Curé et moi je
t'aime et moi je t'aime autant que
lorsqu'on était
[Musique]
fiancé quand une fille une fille de
Provence en mariage VI donner sa main
toutes les pH de le la Provence sansaner
jusqu'au petit matin quand une fille une
fille de Provence en marage les sa main
ce sont tous les fres de la qui sont
épousé les tambourin sous les tonnel de
font vieille on retrouvé t deons dans
les coins sombres cherchant de l'ombre
les filles vont embrasser les garçons
les enfants sages ne sont pas sages mais
aujourd'hui tout leur est pardonné et
moi je t'aime et moi je t'aime aant
queon était
fiancé et moi je t'aime et moi je t'aime
bien depuis que l'on est marié quand une
fille F de prov marage VI don sa main
toutes les parents don de la Provence
sans jusqu'au petit matin quand une
fille fille de Provence en
mar sont les de la prov
[Musique]
quiour